nos piden la enésima suma parcial de
esta serie de adn que está dada por esta
fórmula para los primeros n términos y
nos piden escribir una regla para a m
para saber cuál será el término a n en
sí mismo para ayudarnos vamos a escribir
esto como visualización si yo tengo a
uno más a dos más a tres así
sucesivamente sigo sumando hasta llegar
a a n menos uno más a n todo esto que
acabamos de escribir es sm que es igual
a n 1 entre n 10 y si queremos encontrar
a n que es el objetivo de este ejercicio
pues puedo restar la suma de los
primeros n menos un términos así que
puedo restar esto esto es s n menos uno
que es igual y en donde encuentra la n
la voy a sustituir por n
uno así que esto es n menos uno más uno
n 110 que es igual a n / n 9 así que
vamos a restar lo rojo lo azul y nos va
a quedar lo que buscamos
nos vamos a quedar con n podemos
escribir que n es igual a sn - s n menos
1 y esto es igual a n 1 entre ene 10 - n
entre n 9 y esto solito es la regla de n
pero podemos combinar esto combinamos
estas fracciones y esto se cumplirá para
n mayor a 1 para n igual a 1 s n va a
ser igual a adn o podemos decir que n va
a ser igual a s n cuando en es igual a 1
pero para cualquier otra n podemos usar
esto de aquí y si queremos simplificar
esto pues sumamos estas fracciones y
podemos sumar las si tenemos un común
denominador aquí multiplicamos numerador
y denominador por n 9 nos va a quedar n
1 por n 9
n 10 por n 9 y a esto le restamos aquí
vamos a multiplicar numerador y
denominador por n 10 así que tenemos n
por n 10 entre n 9 por n 10 que nos va a
dar esto bueno si simplificamos aquí
arriba tendremos n cuadrada más 10 m 9 y
aquí tendremos n cuadrada más 10 n y
recuerden que vamos a restar esto y ya
estamos muy cerca de terminar a n va a
ser igual a nuestro denominador n 9 por
n 10 y en el numerador vamos a restar lo
rojo de lo azul n cuadrada - n cuadrada
esto se cancela 10 en menos 10 n también
se cancela y nos quedan 9
hemos escrito una regla para adn para n
mayor que 1